nagyon rosszul esett eleinte hogy
kijelentetted hogy nem mondhatjuk
egymásnak hogy szeretlek de be kellett
ismerjem azt hogy ez ez egy jogos
feladat
mert például ha hozol egy
csokorvirágot akkor azt mondom hogy
szeretlek de ettől te nem érzed szeretve
magad hogy hoztál egy csokorvirágot
tehát merthogy éppen te tettél bele a
kapcsolatunkba mer igen mert nem
tudhatom hogy jól szeretlek- vele tát h
bizos hogy
pontosan tehát hogy ahhoz meg kell
kérdezem most jól szerettelek ezzel a
csakorvirággal nyilván hy a legjobb ha
azt mondom hogy jól szerettél vagy
visszajelzek valahányszor jól szeretsz
mert akkor azt le tudod írni a
kézikönyvedbe hogy ezzel ilyen helyzetbe
jól szeretem üüm és akkor így így a
végül is ezt is csináltuk a házasságunk
elején hogy egymásnól elkezdtünk így
jegyzetelni és így gondolkodni hogy
hogyan lehet a másikat jól szeretni
igen ez a különség a jóágégekig vezetett
ez ez a különbség a jóság és a szeretet
között hogy amikor jó vagyok akkor a
saját magam keretrendszeréből indulok ki
hogy azt adom a másik személynek amit én
gondolok hogy neki jó a szeretet pedig
az amikor megismerem a másikat és azt
adom ami számára jó